Selena Gomez claps back amid her rumored
Feud with Francia Raisa I'm very honest
though in general the drama started
after Selena's recent interview with
rolling stone where she opened up about
feeling like a bit of an outcast in the
world of entertainment explaining quote
I never fit in with a cool group of
girls that were celebrities my only
friend in the industry really is Taylor
Swift so I remember feeling like I
didn't belong yeah she's amazing she's
been she's been in my life for so long
we're kind of like sisters at this point
well a select portion of that quote was
then posted to Instagram my only friend
in the industry really is Taylor Swift
and Franzia in a since deleted comment
cryptically wrote interesting
then when a Tick-Tock user shared a
video breaking down the supposed drama
pointing out that Francia no longer
follows Selena on Instagram Selena slid
into the comments writing sorry I didn't
mention every person I know
he's a 10 but he hates your best friend
I hate her too sometimes
honestly Fair
the two I've been friends for nearly 15
years and in 2017 Francia donated her
kidney to Selena when she needed a
transplant as a result of her battle
with lupus when I had to self-isolate
myself
almost three years ago now because of my
kidney surgery I was depressed I was
frustrated you know I basically had a
C-section it's hard to walk because you
know you got cut into and
um because no one knew what was
happening and fans were quick to point
out that bronzia was nowhere to be found
in Selena's new documentary my mind and
me which details her mental and physical
health struggles over the years
everything that I had gone through it's
going to be there I'm just making it my
friend now I am happier and I'm in
control of my emotions and thoughts more
than I have ever been and while he
didn't name names the film's director
did tell ET some of Selena's friends
were camera shy during filming
everything that was happening in her
life was free reign with the exception
she was very
I think she was very sensitive about
not necessarily having
her sister in the dock and I was also
very sensitive to the fact that some of
her friends didn't want to be filmed we
don't know if Francia was one of those
Pals but we do know that their
friendship runs deep back in 2019 she
opened up to ET about her decision to
donate her organ to her friend in need
it was a decision that was very
faith-based and you know like she and I
have talked about before it just kind of
happened coincidentally but I don't
believe in coincidences I believe that
that's God's way remaining Anonymous and
I'm very grateful for the opportunity
[Music]
foreign